[Applause] Okay,
Well I'm gonna tell you my story now. In 1984 I was a sophomore
at Princeton and I was one of the captains on the fencing team.
And I briefly want to explain fencing to you a little bit. For everyone. There are a
few Jews knew what a Mohel was and certainly the male Jews remember what a Mohel was but for those of
don't know what fencing is I'm going to give you a quick lesson.
lesson. In fencing there are 3 weapons and I'm going to-, um I'm not going to make a joke about
a pen being mightier than the sword but I'm going to use
a pen as a sword tonight which is only fitting since it's the PEN festival. But. So,
quickly fencing there are 3 weapons: the most common weapon that people know about is the foil.
And then foil, the torso is the target area. And you use the tip of the blade. Like that,
and so just the torso, not the arms, only the torso. Another weapon is the épée
and in that. With that weapon. The whole body is
the target including the feet, the legs, the head, everything. But again, you only use the point.
Now the weapon I fenced was saber. And it was, for me, the most dashing, the most romantic,
the most Errol Flynn-like, because the way you scored touches were was
a slashing motion oftentimes I have a real saber when I do this and you would have been in peril. But because I'm
an expert I merely would have just snipped a hair for a moment but very lovely right in the front here.
Anyway, so the saber is a slashing weapon and the whole, and the whole
target area is everything above the hips. Including the head and the arms. And so you make
cutting motions like that, and you slash across the body. And it's very dynamic. So I was
the captain and I loved the romance of fencing. So I named all my fellow
Saber fencers after great swordsmen in history.
There was Sir Gawain, the Green Knight, one sort of goofy freshman we called Don Quixote. And
myself I named El Cid. I was a Charlton Heston fan. This was, um, you know I
loved his face. This was before he was wearing that horrible wig and,
you know, became an NRA spokesman, but even that was OK. He had a great face, you don't see faces
like that every day, so I called myself El Cid after the great Charlton Heston role. Now
Now I had a secret goal that sophomore year at
Princeton. And while training and that was to beat the number one saber fencer at Columbia.
Russell Wilson. My lifetime record against Russell Wilson was about 0 in 13.
I'd been fencing him all through high school. I'd been fencing him at Junior Olympics. He
was always beating me. Once at a party at the Junior Olympics he snubbed me
socially, which only added to my growing wound.
He trained in New York City with like, expatriate Russian coaches, he had incredible
skill. He was snobby, I, he- he was also a lot a little bit chubby. And he had these
sophisticated moves so his whole world view was opposed to mine and. And I was always losing to
him. So my goal, my secret goal sophomore year was to beat Russell Wilson.
Now to get ready for this I would go for early morning lessons with my French fencing coach
at Princeton. Who
was a gorgeous man he had a. He had a bald head. Not that that's gorgeous, but he had a bald head
And beautiful gray eyes kind of look like Sean Connery. He'd been a commando in the in
the Algerian war, the
the French Algerian war. And he would train me early in the morning coming at me with a steel rod
to make my parries extra firm 'cause "you block here, you block here. You block here for the head". And
he'd come at me "El Cid, come on El Cid, commando, commando!". Because he was big into being a commando and he
was seeing me as a possible commando and he would come at me with a steel bar going "commando, commando!".
And I would get ready and he would tell me to be in my own guard position which is like this:"you must have a b- a band of
steel in the groin El Cid". I don't know why we had to have a band of steel down here
but wasn't chaste or anything like that but liked us to have a band of steel down here. Come at me with
this rod. Then afterwards you know he would tell me stories with the war and he would often tell this one
story. He goes, "One time, El Cid, I was walking along on patrol and suddenly an electric cable
shot me in the buttocks and I went flying in the air 30, 40 feet. I was flying through the air, but then I landed on my
feet like a cat! Like a cat, El Cid! That's how you have to be with balance when you fence, El Cid". It was- and then
2 days later he'd be like. "El Cid, one time I was on patrol and electric cables struck me in the buttocks and
I went flying through the air and then I landed on my feet like a cat! That's how you have to be" and I don't know, he was on some
loop
'cause every 2 or 3 days I would hear this electric cables story, in the bottocks and flying through the air
and I'd be like "Yes coach, you're the greatest" you know, he had a huge ego he would claim that when he was my age
he could fly when he went out as someone with his saber you know,
he goes "I became ?plainar?". You know this was ?plainar? like he would be totally flying through the air
with his saber and. Well, somehow at the time I sort of believed him, you know, he said it with
such conviction. Anyway so. We're both training like crazy. Finally the big
meet against Columbia happened, and we took a van from Princeton up to Columbia. And
the coach also wanted me to win terribly because his wife had left him and was shacking
up with the Columbia's coach, he had a thing for swordsman
I guess and so she - he really wanted me to win, we both had a vendetta. So we go up to
Columbia,
and we're in the gym getting ready, and the Columbia team's not around, we're in our white
outfit, stretching, starting to work out a little bit.
And then suddenly the whole gym fills with Wagner music. The r- "The ride of the
Valkyries"right? This scary Wagner music and for me, I'm Jewish and I'm like "What is this,
Wagner?" you know this is Rocky music for the Nazi party this is horrible [laughter]
and then suddenly the Columbia team comes racing in with their white outfits and their
swords trying to intimidate us to this Wagner, like the Nazi party.
And it only made me more ?incense?, made me want to beat Russell Wilson even more.
So anyway, before I got to fence Russell Wilson though I fenced a lesser, the lesser saber guy on the
Columbia team and I LOST to him, I was so keyed on Russell Wilson I lost, which was disastrous.
But our team was still competing, so then finally I got to fence Russell Wilson.
This bout I'd been training months for these, you know, commando lessons with the iron rod in the morning
the, you know, the buttock story, all so I could beat Russell Wilson. I get down in my band
of steel, we're moving back and forth, I think to his head and I cut him across the belly, and I go up 1-0
Now, to win a fencing bout you have to score five touches. And so I was - I had gotten
the first one and when I scored a touch in fencing I would... The language of fencing is French, and
so when I scored the touch I went "et là!", and "et là" means "and there", like: and there you swine,
you fool, you idiot, you know, you- you, you Londoner or something like that. So I, you know
"Et là!". And I, I said it really loud right? And then we're moving back and forth, he tried to come here, boom! I
hit him right in the head, I'm up 2-0.
This is incredible, I'm winning, it's beautiful! That he got a touch 2-1. But then I went
ahead 3-1, this was wonderful. But then he started coming back: 3-2, 3-3,
it's like Oh doh! You know I got down my band of steel and I went ahead 4-3.
But then sure enough he got, you know, he fainted to my head, cut me across the belly: it was now tie
4-4. I could sense it going out of my hands, my inner loser was asserting
[laughter] You know, my whole Oedipal upbringing, my father was always trying to crush me to keep me
out of my mother's bed and everything like that. And so I could just sense it was happening again, oh no, I'm going
to lose it was 4-4.
Now, when it's 4-4 in fencing it's called "La Belle", the beautiful touch, because it's
like the touch right before death.You know the French love the death: le petite mort, le grand mort, they love it all
yea, and so, So 4-4 is La Belle, because if you're recreating a duel to the death
the next touch would be the death touch.
So my coach calls timeout. I lift up my mask. And he starts speaking to me in French
"il va faire le contre-temps"and- and at this point I'm not absorbing any French I've been saying "et là"
with every touch. "et là!" you know
I couldn't get- that was the only French I could get out of me, or in me. But he's giving me all these
instructions with French and I'm going "OK coach". But I sense I'm going to lose and... so he walked
off, my mask came down. And then he turned and looked at me with these beautiful bullet grey eyes
he had
and he said: "Commando". And that was like our secret communication [laughter]
Commando! The iron rod, everything. OK I've g- so I got down in my band of steel
and I decided to do something very risky.
I was going to - I'd try to win by playing it defensive, because I knew Russell Wilson he wanted
to really humiliate me and one way to humiliate a saber fence or, the hand would also be target
area
And in fencing you're supposed to keep your hand back. But to keep your balance sometimes you would come forward and even
though it's sort of macho and Errol Flynn like, it does look a little ?flip Fayez? as you're kind of moving forward with this
hand
kind of very genteel and you know, the pinky up or something like that, but anyway: my hand
was out and I knew he was going to want to cut it. To really defeat me terribly. So I kind of kept it
out there almost like a choke fisherman with a lure.
Come on Russell Wilson, go over my hand, try to humiliate me, I know you're a sadist
you snubbed me at that party in Cleveland. Come on, cut my head! So I was leaving
it dangling out there, right? now the danger was um, when I went to parry if I went too
far, if I overcompensated, he would quickly move and cut me here. That was the danger of going
for that. So-
but I leave it out there, I'm leaving it out there, I'm drawing him in, he's moving back and forth, it's a beautiful dance, fencing.
And then suddenly sure enough,
he makes his move he goes from my hand. I wait till last I can...boom. I parry him
it was beautiful, it was delicious, it was a wonderful clang of steel
I had him blocked. Now, and his head was right there because it extended him so. So all I had to do was
go like that, tap him right on the head. And I win. All I had to do is go and tap him right on the head.
Now in fencing, like everything in life, the closest distance between two points is a straight line. So just like that
play now! like the coach has been tel- telling me. But instead like an idiot, like an inner
loser, like blinded Oedipus I rear back leg that exposing my arm.
You fool! I sense my foolishness. But Russell Wilson was so shocked that I parried and I still had time.
So I compensate and I came down ferociously on top of his head like that "Et là!" and
I went so nuts, so much craziness, my whole life! So much confusion,
All came out right on his head. And my saber
snapped and broke over his head, went flying into the air, [laughter] probably blinded
a ?coeditor? you know, Barnard, it went flying into the air, it was beautiful. And I went
like that, and I had scored the touch, but then I went nuts like I started going
"Et là! Et là! Et là! Et là! Et là! Et là! Et là!"
It was like I had French Tourette, I was like a dog into the alleyway making love like the
greatest lover ever. Up and down, this pumping motion the Et là!s
the whole place was going crazy and the judge was actually a Holocaust survivor. With one eye
and a lump, and a bad leg. Somehow he'd seen this. Nobody could miss that I had broken the blade over his head.
And he goes "touch to the left to Ames, to Princeton". And I had won! whoever wins in life? No one,
that's why we're here tonight, you never win!
But I had won and I was lifted up by my teammates, the greatest fencing victory of my life.
I was ebullient and then I saw Russell Wilson
down below just kind of dizzy. And I said "oh, nice bout" completely disingenuous
but showing good form. And we shook hands and so that is the story of my greatest fencing
victory
[laughter, applause]
Thank you
[applause] So, just
2 little quick thing, almost like a coda. Um, several years later I was
at a dinner party. I mean a few years ago. At a dinner party and several years after the fact and I took
my knife and I told the story. And a girl at the dinner said "I know Russell Wilson,
he's an arms dealer now for the government" I was like "What?". Anyway. So then I was like
"Wow, well I defeated him, you know". And I don't care about him and going in helicopters over the Middle East
but, anyway. So then she emails me like a week later : "I mentioned you to Russell Wilson. He said
he didn't remember you"
[laughter] So, snatched it away from me! Anyway, thank
you
[applause]
thank.